have copious amounts of debt 60k student
loan debt Flash 2 years later attention
is the number one asset on the left you
and I meet at a Milwaukee Airport 2017
I'm drowning in Deb yes I have copious
amounts of debt 60k student loan debt
Flash 2 years later flip life paid off
the student debt all thanks to trash
talk what was the first item that you
flipped that really made you say wait a
minute this dude Gary isn't
joking no joke started as a couch our
neighbor gave us a couch sitting in our
basement for years it was all denim a
denim je couch wait a minute you sold a
rare Den you probably sold it too cheap
Under by the way I think you got ripped
off I know you made money but I have a
weird feeling that somebody's sitting
right now telling a story of how they
ripped off a young Irishman for this
rare denim couch you got it for free got
it for free y 180 bucks Craigslist uh
face to Marketplace and yeah uh and then
I was